- [Voiceover] What I wanna
talk about in this video
is shapes with four sides,
and the mathy word for
shapes with four sides
is quadrilateral.
Quadrilateral.
And any time you see
quad as part of a word,
it's a good, it's a good sign
that you're dealing with
the number four somehow.
So a quadrilateral is
something that has four sides.
So that is a quadrilateral,
this is a quadrilateral,
this is a quadrilateral.
They all have four sides.
This is a quadrilateral.
even this is a,
let me make it look even weirder,
even this is a quadrilateral.
So what's not a quadrilateral?
Well, a triangle would
not be a quadrilateral.
It has three sides,
one, two, three.
So let's cross that out.
A pentagon that has five sides,
that would not be a quadrilateral.
It has one, two, three, four, five sides.
A circle that has, I guess
you could say, no sides,
it's just one big curve, it's a circle.
That's not going to be a quadrilateral.
If you had six sides, seven
sides, a hundred sides,
none of that is going
to be a quadrilateral.
So now let's think about
the different types of quadrilaterals,
or the different categories
of quadrilaterals.
So one is the parallelogram.
So a parallelogram is a quadrilateral,
and as we learn more math,
we'll learn other ways
of thinking about this.
It's a quadrilateral where
opposite sides are parallel.
And parallel is just another way of saying
that they're going in the same direction.
So what do I mean by that?
So something like this,
something like this,
would be a parallelogram.
Why?
Because this side is
opposite to this side,
and they're pointed in the same direction.
They're going,
they're going, if I were to draw an arrow,
if I were to draw an arrow here,
those arrows are pointed in the same way.
So those two sides are pointed,
are parallel, is the word we say.
And these two sides,
these two sides right
over here are parallel.
So this is a parallelogram.
So what are other
examples of parallelogram?
Well even your classic square,
even your classic square,
is a parallelogram.
And we'll talk more about
what makes a square special.
It's a special type of parallelogram
because this side
is going in the same
direction as that side,
and this side, and this side,
whoops, let me do that in yellow,
and this side is parallel to that side.
So what's not a parallelogram?
Well, something like,
something like this
would not be a parallelogram.
You might say, "Wait,
"I see two opposite sides are parallel."
You might say, "Look,
this is parallel to this."
But then you would see that
this is not parallel to this.
One way to think about some
things that are not parallel
is if the lines kept going,
they would cross each other at some point,
while these lines,
these lines right over here,
they're never going to cross each other.
So this one right over here
is not a parallelogram.
It has one set of opposite
sides being parallel,
but not the other.
Another example of something
that is not a parallelogram
would be this one right over here,
because none of the
opposite sides are parallel.
So parallelogram, opposite
sides are parallel.
So now let's talk about,
let's talk about more
types of four sided shapes,
or quadrilaterals.
So the next one we'll
talk about is the rhombus.
So the rhombus is a type of parallelogram.
The opposite sides need to be parallel,
but that's not, by itself,
that doesn't make it a rhombus.
The opposite sides need to be parallel,
and all the sides have to be equal.
So for example,
this that I'm drawing,
that is a parallelogram,
but it is not a rhombus.
It's a parallelogram because that side,
these opposite sides are parallel.
If they kept going, they
would not cross each other.
And these two opposite sides are parallel.
So it's a parallelogram,
but it's not a rhombus
because the blue sides are
longer than the yellow sides.
So that is not a rhombus.
A rhombus would have to look like this.
A rhombus would have to look like that.
So opposite sides are parallel
and all the sides are the same length.
And now you might say, "Well
maybe a square is a rhombus,"
and I want you to think about that.
Is a square a rhombus?
Are all the sides the same length,
and are the opposite sides parallel?
Well we already said
that the opposite sides
of a square are parallel.
A square is a parallelogram.
And all the sides of a
square are the same length.
So a square is a rhombus.
So one way to think about
rhombuses, or rhombi,
is they're squares,
and you could kind of view them as
kind of a pushed over version of squares,
if a square was moving
really, really, really fast in a cartoon,
that's what my brain thinks
of when I think of a rhombus.
So now let's think of rectangle.
And you might have heard the
word rectangle in the past,
but let's think a little bit more
about what makes a rectangle.
So a rectangle is going
to be a parallelogram,
but that by itself does
not make it a rectangle.
So for example, this right
over here is a rectangle.
Why is it?
Well it's definitely a parallelogram.
This side and that side are parallel.
They'll never intersect.
And this side and this side are parallel.
They're never, they're
never going to intersect
if you kept going on and on and on,
or they're never going
to cross each other.
But what makes it a rectangle?
It's definitely a parallelogram,
but what makes it, why do
we use the word rectangle?
Well one way to think about it is
they way that they come
together at the corners.
So in a rectangle, the things come in to,
I guess you could call
them square corners.
And that's called a right angle.
That's called a right
angle right over there.
So this is what makes a rectangle.
It's a parallelogram where all
the corners are right angles.
You could put a little square there,
if you wanna think about it that way.
So for example, this right over here
would not be a rectangle.
Why?
Cause you can't, if you
put a square here, notice.
That does not, a square
doesn't fit in the corners
the way that it fits right over here.
That you have, the square
does not fit over here.
This is a parallelogram,
but not a rectangle.
A rectangle is a parallelogram
that has square corners.
But what about our square?
Is a square a rectangle?
Well let's draw it out.
Well let's think about it.
A square, opposite sides are parallel.
We've already said it's a parallelogram.
And a square has,
the corners are square.
That's where when people
say make a square corner,
that's where it comes from.
The corners are square.
They are at right angles.
So the square is a rectangle.
So the square is a really
interesting quadrilateral,
because a square falls in
to all of these categories.
The square, a square is a square,
it's a rhombus,
it's the type of rhombus
where the corners are right angles,
or you could say where
the corners are square.
This one right over here is not a square,
this one is square.
They're both rhombuses,
or they're both rhombi.
A square is also a rectangle.
It's a parallelogram where
the corners are right angles,
where they are square.
A square is definitely a parallelogram,
and everything we've talked
about is a quadrilateral.